[Applause]
they're refusing patients at this
hospital all patients that is except
those suspected of having novel
coronavirus the medical staff at this
point of the epidemic taking no chances
in full gear
the woman accompanying the patient
protected only by a mask the number of
cases keep sleeping this apparently just
the latest the top Chinese officials are
even more worried about what happens
next
huzzah from that leading fire made sure
to fumble easier from what we do you
push it off Trump of it Pingu from that
yeah you know Colonel Young's from there
doc he for our future mr. Lee pointed to
this food market as the source of the
initial outbreak
he said that illegal wildlife was being
sold here this markets been closed since
the end of December we've been speaking
to some locals though who've been
applying to get conversation because
their equipments still in these stores
and in terms that disinfection effort
well these are some of the remnants of
you've got masks gloves overrules
they've just been left there on the side
and that is slightly worrying because
this really this market is cheek and
jowl with the rest of the neighborhood
people aren't there so if there is still
contamination here that might have an
effect elsewhere there's a heavy
official presence here as they try to
control the situation
well wildlife and poetry has now been
banned from Wuhan
and officials have imposed travel
restrictions warning people to make only
necessary journeys
it may look busy enough but this train
station should be packed
Chinese New Year on Saturday people are
staying away this is a critical period
for managing the mystery virus Chinese
New Year feels less a celebration than a
risk a trial in the containment of this
outbreak Tom Cheshire Sky News Wuhan
central China